thanks joe yeah there was some confusion
from the secretary of state's office
about when
additional election results would be
reported but we now know
no additional numbers will be reported
tonight
it will now be tomorrow now the deputy
secretary of state for elections
explained his team knows the public
wants more results but
he has been saying before the election
they would not be final on election
night
all active registered voters in nevada
were sent mail-in ballots for the first
time ever due to the covet-19 pandemic
in case they didn't want to vote in
person
ballots may still be in the mail some
signatures need to be confirmed by
voters if they were rejected
and there was a record number of mail-in
ballots already received
now president trump has said nevada
would steal the election
and he's criticized the system here
here's what thorley says
any evidence of voter fraud in nevada so
far
no no evidence whatsoever
of coordinated widespread
voter fraud we have
received a handful of complaints with
some allegations
again they're just allegations at this
point unproven uh that we're looking
into
but no no evidence of voter fraud
i asked for a specific number being
investigated thorley said
less than 10 and that law enforcement is
involved
in those investigations and as we've
reported
30 polling locations in clark county
were ordered by a judge to stay open
an extra hour until 8 pm instead of
7 pm that's after the trump campaign and
the nevada republican party filed a
lawsuit to keep them open because some
locations
had technical difficulties and got a
late start now i asked thorley how that
could have
affected our election keeping them open
one hour later he wouldn't comment on
any lawsuits but he did say it just
meant the results came
in an hour later reporting live vanessa
murphy
8 news now